gratulations do you believe you call
yourself the bad-news babes a strong win
over a championship congressional
women's softball at the game last night
I'm very proud of our team though from
Congress Democratic women Republican
women senators and House members in
unity playing the press I wasn't asking
for any credentials of some of those
shall we say younger players but it was
a great game you did well and we also be
very proud that the event raised three
hundred sixty five thousand dollars to
benefit young survival the young
survival coalition of breast cancer
charity especially geared to young women
who are geared toward diagnosed was
cancer and it was always a joy to see
the survivors last last there last night
we're very proud of Debbie
wasserman-schultz our own young survivor
who has been the leader in all of this
speaking of health care we're very proud
that over the weekend 140 members of the
house Democratic caucus participated in
events across the country events that
were about town halls press conferences
online all the rest talking about
preserving the pre-existing condition
preserving health access to quality
affordable health care it was just
beautiful to behold the stories that
people told about their situations I had
one in the Bay Area with my colleagues
Jackie Speier and Mike Thompson and then
in Southern California with
congresswoman Judy Chu but members again
this was a drumbeat across America which
will continue on the issue the very
important issue to America's working
families health care it's a health issue
it's also a financial security issue
because of the cost of prescription
drugs which we are determined to do
something about hopefully in a
bipartisan way but in the meantime we
have to stop the Republican and the
president's assault on the pre-existing
condition benefit on the Affordable Care
Act it's just remarkable that the
Affordable Care Act is the law of the
land it is a responsibility of the
Justice Department to defend the law of
the land in
instead this administration has
instructed the Justice Department to
oppose the law of the land and
completely undo the Affordable Care Act
including removing the benefit of
pre-existing conditions lifetime limits
on insurance that shield insurance
companies are supposed to provide the
list goes on and on
also now this week we're coming toward
the end of the appropriation passing all
of our appropriations bill it is a
wonderful process to behold I'm a from
the culture of the Appropriations
Committee so I have always said left to
their own devices the appropriators
Democrats and Republicans working
together can produce good legislation
and they are and I am trying to defend
the number at which they are writing the
bills in their conversations with the
White House about rate lifting lifting
the caps and so that's where we are on
that we're hopefully making progress as
we come to the end of passing our own
bills in addition to that we all know
that we want to avoid a sequestration
but that we won't avoid a continuing
resolution but we have to would have to
meet the needs of the American people in
a way that is reflected in our
appropriations bill so so we will almost
be finished this week there might be one
for after the fourth of July a tribute
to Stanny hire who are a leader on the
floor who has in spite of the
interventions from the other side for a
roll call vote on every amendment
nonetheless tried to stay on schedule
with all of this and next week we'll
take up a few more bills as well as a
very important legislation for election
security congresswoman's O'Laughlin
chair of the House Administration
Committee whose jurisdiction this bill
is will be put in force legislation but
it's only step one it's about it's about
preventing foreign intervention
in our elections but also it put this
particular piece of it is about
protecting our electoral system and
allocating resources to help States do
so when we come back working with many
of our members on other proposals that
they have in trying to work in the most
bipartisan way possible we will have
other legislation to prevent foreign
intervention including the duty to
report rules and sanctions that will be
put forth as a warning to countries not
to interfere into our elections
especially Russia and if the legislation
to promote transparency and
accountability in the legislation this
is again about the integrity of our
elections obviously it's very clear that
the Russians disrupted our elections
there's no doubt in terms of the
intelligence reporting at the highest
confidence level that that happened and
that is continues to happen and yet the
President of the United States who takes
an office to protect and defend our
Constitution and therefore our democracy
is saying that that Russian interference
in our election that charge is a hoax
and that in fact not only does he call
it a hoax and not want to do anything to
stop it
he and his comments have given a green
light to the Russians to continue to do
it it's really quite stunning so there
we are we have the leader in the Senate
the grim reaper still saying he's going
to stop any legislation that goes over
there I hope that he will honor his oath
about this by helping to protect our
democracy by protecting the integrity of
our elections so this is the day we
welcome Prime Minister Trudeau to the
Capitol as it turns out and timely
fashion for me to what would be the word
pay off my debt the bet is that with the
way I said okay settle the debt with
beautiful California of chocolate Powell
tomorrow your Amin's that's how we say
in California almonds
California walnuts California pistachios
sorry your wine that we get back to the
chocolates because we'll have more than
one variety
and to do so congratulating the rafters
but also saying that they won against
mighty champs the salmon says the Golden
State Warriors soon to come to reside in
San Francisco and today at 3 o'clock the
women play Sweden isn't that exciting
and soccer at that time I will be
settling the debt it's 3 o'clock at our
press event with with the Prime Minister
we'll talk about other things including
trade I'm sure but we had to settle up
first
any questions well first of all we are
going to Emma delete some reason we
called the meeting earlier today and
thank you for accommodating that is that
at 11:00 o'clock we will have a briefing
I think it's now expanded a gang of 20
that includes leadership and senior
members Democrats and Republicans House
and Senate on committees of jurisdiction
and so we'll learn more in that briefing
as to what is happening there I think
it's a dangerous situation high tension
wires are up in the region we have to be
strong and strategic about how we
protect our interest we also cannot be
reckless and what we do so it will be
interesting to see what they have to say
whether the I don't think the president
wants to go to war there's no appetite
for going to war in our country and so
we want to see what they have to say and
then I have called for a broader
briefing for more members but they're
starting with this briefing this morning
so this afternoon from between 4:00 and
5:00 I'll have a meeting for my members
to hear from some experts on the Iran
project Wendy Sherman ambassador Wendy
Sherman ambassador William Blair's head
of the Iran project Wendy lowers our
former and
who helped negotiate the Iran nuclear
agreement as well as John Brennan I
think that authenticity is the most
important characteristic that candidates
have to convey to the American people
and Joe Barney is authentic he has lived
his life he considers certain things a
resource that he has worked across the
aisle that's what he was saying that's
not what this election is about this
election is about how we connect with
the American people addressing their
kitchen table needs for us to spend time
on an issue like this which is important
but it's not central to what the
election is about what the election is
about is the financial stability and
well-being of America's working families
central to that is lowering health care
costs by lowering the cost of
prescription drugs bigger paychecks by
creating more opportunities building the
infrastructure of America in a green way
and having cleaner government by giving
them the assurance that what we do here
is in the public and the people's
interest not the special dark money
interest that's what the election is
about so while we all have a great
vision all of our candidates and I'm
proud of every one of them have a great
vision about our country and how we go
forward know their specialties very well
and have good judgment and can talk
strategically about how they will get it
done
just watch them on can't wait to see
that debates but all of that is up here
the vision the knowledge the strategic
thinking
heart to heart where they connect with
the American people
showing them that they have an
understanding their hopes and dreams
aspirations fears as well as
apprehensions that's what the election
will be about on the same topic the
argument from senator Booker and others
of course is that Vice President Biden
is disconnecting with a large group of
Americans especially African Americans
who have a problem with his rhetoric of
course as you say senator Biden or Vice
President Biden he's saying
authentically he feels strongly about
what he said that it was proper what do
you think about Vice President Biden's
words referencing his work with
segregationist and talking about his
idea of civility I answered that
question that's all I'm going to say
about it we have massive challenges to
our democracy whether it's the integrity
of our elections whether it's the values
in our budgets that we put forth whether
it's a respect for the people of our
country a nation of immigrants unless
you're blessed to be born a Native
American and and that's a beautiful
thing but we have a White House that
says we disrespect America
redistribution of America what is
America America is the Constitution and
our rights contained therein we do not
support our oath of office because we're
walking away from checks and balances
freedom of the press and the rest where
does America America is a nation of
immigrants and we will denigrate them as
opposed to what Ronald Reagan said about
immigrants and the constant vitality
they bring to America where is America
this beautiful land that God has given
us from sea to shining sea and beyond
and this nation this administration is
degrading of that beautiful environment
as recently as yesterday with their
dirty Power scam that they put forth to
diminish the air that our children
breathe what is America about our values
what our values which are our values a
budget should be a statement of our
national values that's what is important
to our country as to what we think is
important in how we invest in the few
for our children that's what we should
be talking about it remains for the
candidates to debate among themselves
who among them will appeal Joe Biden
seems to have tremendous support in the
african-american community but it's for
them to decide it's not for me to make a
judgement as to how they're going to to
react to him that's what elections are
about let's see who connects with the
American people
let the election it's not that's not for
us to say this is who we think should be
the candidate for president it's for the
people to decide so we can have this
discussion here all we want while the
president is calling an attack on our
democracy a hoax while the
administration is shutting down up the
protections of clean air for our
families why that list goes on and on so
I'm not going to go to that place I've
said what I'm going to say about it and
let them all debate it we'll see that
two nights next week and I'm very
excited about it because I think any one
of them would be a better president than
the current occupant of the White House
thank you for trying Ben inissia god
forbid what's your view on why tensions
arising between these two nations right
now
well the let me just say that this I'm
was very much a strong supporter and I
think played an important role in
protecting the Iran nuclear agreement
that is something that was very very
positive and stopping arounf slowing any
process for a number of years as to
Iran's intentions in terms of developing
a nuclear weapon when we walked away
from that we lost some credibility with
our allies I think what however we go
forward without saying how we got here
however we go what we have to recognize
that working together with our allies is
very very important and that we cannot
throw our weight around but you know we
have to do this together I there's
nobody who has any illusions about Iran
their bad behavior in terms of who they
support
in the region they're spreading of
ballistic missiles and we have sanctions
on all of that but this is a dangerous
neighborhood and miscalculation on
either side could provoke something that
would be very bad in terms of the
security and our interest so let's look
forward to the briefing I go there with
concerns about our how we are not how we
should be doing better working with our
allies but also listening to what the
intelligence has to say about it I think
it's really important I said that some
did some of you at breakfast yesterday
it's important for the American people
to understand what is happening there
but how many articles how many news
reports did I read about attacks on
ships that never said the ships were
Saudi Arabian were Norwegian we're
Japanese right at the same time when the
Japanese Prime Minister premier was that
in Tehran so you know let's make sure
that that we don't have a beating the
drum for something without the clarity
of the facts involved and again our
responsibility is to protect and defend
our Constitution American people our
country that's our first responsibility
that's what we will honor but let's get
let us get the facts as to how we got to
this place I don't want to make any
characterizations about it but I will
say that we've started to lose
credibility on the subject when we
walked away from the nuclear Iran
nuclear agreement
this had to be the last because we have
the hearing do we have to waste time on
Mike more than your characterization of
my remarks I mean I trust you but my
gratis why do we private credit practice
a question to me about Mike Mulvaney's
mischaracterization of my remarks I have
we will never question the Full Faith
and Credit of the United States of
America it's in the Constitution of the
United States
Mulvaney is one of the people shut down
government because they didn't want to
lift the debt ceiling and so he has no
credibility on this subject whatsoever
so my I mean I shouldn't even be engaged
in any conversation that has him
mischaracterizing we have never said we
would not live support what we have said
though is that we will fight for meeting
the needs of the American people i
bragged at the beginning about the good
work that the probations committee is
doing we want to come as close to their
numbers possible in the discussions and
that when the Republicans threatened to
not lift the debt ceiling as you may
recall a few years ago just the threat
of it just the threat of it because it
was a very legitimate threat and people
were scared lowered the credit rating of
the United States of America and he was
part of that so I didn't know please
don't predicated a kind of
characterization of a question like I
have never changed my view on the
subject what we have said is we have to
deal with these things sequentially and
we will thank you all very much